déjà comment se déroulerait une guerre
nucléaire une guerre nucléaire serait
évidemment dévastatrice pour une grande
partie de l'humanité des chercheurs de
l'université de princeton on étudie les
hypothèses les plus probables d'une
telle guerre et on en fait une
simulation the war qui fait froid dans
le dos et voir c'est incroyable je vous
montre comment ça pourrait se passer
vous à vous ça fait flipper mais on
voulait vous le montrer quand même ce
soir parce que tout le monde n'a parlé
que de ça ce week-end alors phase 1 on
part de l'hypothèse d'une première
frappe nucléaire d'avertissement russe
immédiatement l'otan réplique ray donc
voilà donc comment comment ça se
passerait général
premier point je vais vous décevoir mais
ça ne se passerait pas d'accord
il faut bien voir que la vision russe de
l'utilisation d'armes nucléaires et
soviétiques je parle sous le contrôle de
sergei est très différente de la vision
que nous avons nous de l'utilisation de
l'armé nucléaire nous leur nucléaire
c'est une arme de non-emploi alors je
m'explique ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'on n'utilisera pas l'arme
nucléaire en premier emploi on
l'utilisera que si on nous fera c'est ça
du côté soviétique autrefois et russes
maintenant
c'est une arme d'emplois c'est à dire
que lorsqu'il y a un problème
qui met à mal l'armée russe il y as
possibilité d'employer de l'arme
nucléaire de bas niveau qu'on appelle
tactique qui peut amener à des escalades
donc il faut bien voir que c'est on a
vraiment des conceptions tout à fait
différente mais si vous le permettez je
reviens juste sur la présentation que le
président poutine a fait oui si vous
voulez qu'il annonce qu'il mettait en
alerte l'armement stratégique nucléaire
me fait sourire il est forcément en
alerte s'ils n'étaient pas en alerte y
servir à quoi ouais il est forcément en
alerte donc c'est un aspect de
communication qu'il veut avoir pour dire
attention
j'ai quelques problèmes actuellement en
ukraine ouais mais je suis capable
d'aller plus haut donc c'est plus de la
communication que de l'emploi ceci étant
ça veut pas dire que ce soit pas
inquiétants mais bien sûr placer on
s'est tous posé la question bien sûr
c'est vrai qu'on a tous vu des potes ce
week-end quels seraient les effets d'une
bombe nucléaire sur paris si on prend le
cas de la bombe russe
bon bah la plus puissante de l'histoire
qui est trois mille fois plus puissante
que les banques qui ont rasé hiroshima
et nagasaki nagasaki le scénario fait
froid dans le dos puisque la boule de
feu nucléaire serait 213 kilomètres
carrés de souffle valérie une surface de
200 km² détruisant les bâtiments en
béton et faisant presque 100 % de décès
le bilan humain serait à peine croyable
plus de 6 millions de personnes périrent
est dans la catastrophe c'est incroyable
c'est que j'y le srec ou data a étudié
au 6 rue oui bien sûr et et aujourd'hui
ils ont le fameux sac à dos et le dérivé
de tsar bomba dont on dit que 100 tonnes
10000 km de portée mon général cette
bombe elle peut nous détruire bien sûr
mais c'est pour ça que je répète ça ne
sera pas utilisée parce que la réplique
est au moins aussi dramatique que l'onac
oui mais ce qu israël vous savez on
appelait samad mutuelle destruction on
va s'accuser de la destruction mutuelle
d'accord vous m'attaquez 20 et détruisez
mais moi je vous détruit aussi qui est
gagnant même osé stationner lui il est
rationnel général dans les séries
sergei parce que comme vous dites venir
poutine on parle de la réplique mais
peut-être qu'ils s'en fout de la
république non je crois que je ne crois
pas or encore que il est perdu raison
en revanche je suis d'accord et pour mon
général c'est que nous avons une un
système qui est différent de reason de
raisonner et je peux rajouter encore un
truc c'est que oui dit pour nous l'armée
utilisable pire l'armée est utilisable
contrat pitt il n'a pas d'armes
nucléaires
c'est encore pire ça veut dire que le
cren qui n'a pas d'armes nucléaires
poutine enfin ma source qui est très
inquiétante elle a dit que pour vous
impressionner et pour vous montrer qu'il
est un cas par cas pas de ça
demain après demain dans trois jours
dans une semaine et il est capable de
faire sauter une petite bombe tactique
d'une kilotonnes qui ne fera pas les
dégâts que vous avez décrit mais quand
même parce que ça c'est la bombe
thermonucléaire c'est la plus puissante
c'est 100 kilos tonnes en couleurs
bombes thermonucléaires les rues les
russes auront
on sépare parce que c'est un secret déjà
pour commencer le nombre exact oui le
nombre exact on sait que les russes
possèdent
6235 tête jusque là yves ogives
nucléaires parmi lesquels on sait pas
combien il ya de termine clair parce que
c'est un saint c'est comme il est à
penser qu'il peut utiliser une bombe
nucléaire un petit mais contre l'ukraine
canton l'ukraine pourquoi pour eux parce
que le cren n'a pas de répondre c'est
parce que le général vous a expliqué si
vous utilisez ça contre l'occident
l'occident emploie la même chose contre
vous et non seulement on se détruit les
uns les autres mais la planète détruite
bien sûr parce que les 5000 et 6000 ou
là la seconde a même pensé à ça on s'est
dit il y pas
pardon on part d'un principe convient
peut-être que maintenant je n'ai pas
idée il est peut-être malade il a pleuré
la perte c'est ce qu'on dit des gilles
ans c'est ça absolument c'est si jamais
dans sa tête il sent qu'il a plus que
quelques années à vivre si c'est un
jusqu'au boutiste pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
à regret pas la bombe est à prévoir la
fin du monde moi j'ai pas j'ai pas la
réponse je n'ai pas la réponse est
peut-être je veux pas te général l'a
jugé pas la réponse parce que je peux
pas être dans leurs attaques monsieur
poutine mais tout système a ses failles
et
je ne sais pas si certains d'entre vous
ont vu le film le champ du loup oui
alors il ya du cinéma là dedans 20 mai
au bout du mot compte il n'y a pas que
le président qui appuie sur un bouton
toute une chaîne c'est une chaîne d vous
voulez aujourd'hui ce que je me dis
c'est que si le président poutine arrivé
dans les extrêmes il ya probablement un
premier cercle autour de lui qui est qu
elle un peu plus raisonnable et qui dira
non on va pas jusque là mais vous me
dites
il écoute personnes mais en même temps
il ya quand même pour faire sauter par
exemple une bombe nucléaire il ya un
protocole ya un protocole il faut déjà
être au moins deux donc en fait les
points communs comme odile à la valise
atomique en fait la valise nucléaire il
ya trois personnes qui la possède donc
c'est lui c'est au choix vous ne me nice
d de la défense quand vous l'avez dit
oui voilà et le le commandant d'état
d'état major le chef d'état major des
armées donc il faut au moins deux
d'accord déjà pour pour mettre les codes
pour ouvrir les codes il faut qu'il ya
deux commandements après pour la
graduation
c'est pas forcément enfin je comprends
que vous l'avez vous n'avez pas voulu
effrayer le public mais en fait aux
états unis par exemple vous avez des
dégrade ça s'appelle boeuf comme il ya
cinq niveaux d'edf comme le cinquième
niveau c c'est le plus bas c'est la vie
de tous les jours en fait ça veut dire
que tous les jours il ya des missiles
qui sont armés qui sont préparés pour
être pour être non c'est tout le monde
personne ne sait personne ne sait quel
missile et préparer aujourd'hui dans
quel endroit et et combien vous avez des
sous marins atomiques qui sow qui se
cache quelque part personne ne sait vous
avez par exemple les sous marins
atomiques qui part pendant un mois deux
mois six mois dans les fonds de
résolution pour être pour après faire
surface et fait refaire le feu et ça
personne ne sait ça c'est tous les jours
en revanche ce que poutine a dit
avant-hier il a dit ça passe de niveau 5
au niveau 3
le niveau 5 c'est quoi le niveau 3 donc
ces sous marins etc ces missiles sont
préparés mais par exemple qu'on ne met
pas les cibles dans les ordinateurs de
ses deux deux de ces missiles là ils ont
mis les cibles ils ont mis les cibles ah
ouais après il ya encore deux niveaux de
niveau c'est au nouveau nikon et le 3 et
le niveau le plus haut on appuie sur le
bouton ah ouais donc on n'est pas encore
à son niveau 3 quand même c'est 6 bis
ils sont au niveau ton si le problème
c'est que quand poutine dit nous on
passe au niveau 3 c'est incroyable ce
que voient les états unis sont obligés
c'est de passer aux mets mais c'est ça
et donc sauf que ce sauf que vous le
savez
comme vous le disiez il ya des sous
marins qui sont en france la france un
sous marin nucléaire lanceur d'engins
qui est prêt mais il ya des exercices
qui offusque au niveau 3 régulièrement
absolument comme des exercices dont on
n'a jamais parlé oui sauf que là on l'a
dit devant tout le monde ouais ça
gateway oui sa game et si si
effectivement au niveau 3 les russes ont
déjà ciblé j'imagine des villes
ukrainiennes si les américains eux ont
ciblé ils ont ciblé quoi c'est ça ça a
tout fait savoir ouais en fait et les
russes à haut niveau 3 ils ont ensuite
pas cibler les villes ukrainiennes les
stratégies qu'ils ont signé les villes
américaines françaises allemandes et
japonaises chinoises ont laissé dans le
monde entier région
dans les endroits stratégiques oui tous
les endroits stratégiques pas ça parce
que la france possède deux cent
quatre-vingt dix ogives et les états
unis peuvent ils peuvent toucher
parce qu'il ya les missiles stratégiques
les missiles stratégiques peuvent
toucher n'importe quel point sur la
planète mais on est dans une bulle et
avec l'avé qu'avec les sous marins on
peut s'approcher de n'importe quel côté
il ya un sous marin russe ce qui peut
arriver un homme en normandie ou à
marseille est tiré
est-ce qu'on possède nous comme comme
israël comme les états unis le tome
c'est à dire pour intercepter des
missiles non les missiles patriot qui
ont été déployés en europe au large de
l'europe n'y en a pas en france mais
c'est une protection effectivement
fournie par les américains au pays de
l'otan d'accord mais douze ailleurs de
l'intérêt de le temps mais si l'option
nucléaire qui arrive je dire voir
comment ça se passe elle met combien de
temps à arriver comment savez comment ça
se passe non mais alors évidemment si on
rentre dans le détail de la technologie
d'aujourd'hui en particulier les
missiles hyper véloce un qu'on n'a pas
on va pas aller étudier toute cette
technologie mais il est probable que les
missiles patriot ne sont pas en mesure
d'arrêter des missiles hyper véloce et
donc les probables mais ça mais on n'a
aucun mais comment toi régentant grimace
il tire de marseille ça va en deux
minutes en 3 minutes en cinq minutes à
paris ah ouais d'accord mais ils peuvent
donc et donc c'est quoi le truc il faut
faire mais
qui qui qui tire de dix ans et la
sculpture de lille ou de grand lille ces
deux minutes deux minutes ah ouais donc
c'est essayer est-ce que c'est paris qui
sera visé en premier 2 c'est ce que
c'est paris qui sera visé en premier
c'est la france sur la france en général
quand on quand on commence une grande
guerre c'est toujours la capitale qui
est visé en premier après c'est les
cibles nucléaire ça veut dire c'est les
mêmes missile qui que possèdent les
etats-unis la france et d'autres pays
nucléaires alors angleterre qui seront
qui sont visés les moyens de voir quels
sous marin est posté quelque part mais
si on en a les moyens il ya les
satellites qui qu'ils font tout le temps
il ya les radars qui est qui surveille
le territoire sauf que sauf que en deux
minutes même si vous vous le voyez où
pourra plus rien faire non mais attendez
l'amélioration des systèmes c'est pour
ça que la france améliore en permanence
ces sous marins nucléaires lanceurs
d'engins c'est précisément pour qu'on ne
les voit pas c'est à dire que ils
sortent il se dit lui c'est ça le
disaient ils se fondent dans un fonds ou
oléron ne les repèrent pas et ils
attendent là ils attendent et donc il
attend des équipages passé quatre mois à
attendre l'ordre dont il espère qu'il ne
viendra pas a priori rien à faire ça et
regagne donc si ça repart de marseille
comme vous dites ça dure c'est ça arrive
en cinq minutes à paris de toute façon
y'a rien à faire plus rien à faire c'est
pour ça que je vous disais que ceux ci
n'aura pas lieu pourquoi parce que dès
qu'un pays la russie les états unis la
france la chine envoie un missile
nucléaire stratégique
oui immédiatement la riposte est envoyée
donc c'est la destruction mutuellement
là ça veut dire quand
mais ils on dira que on peut rien faire
pour la battre on a le temps d'appuyer
sur le nôtre il a juste le temps de la
riposte bon alors mais bon mais oui mais
mais c'est ce que dira ni celle ci dit
il ya trois personnes on l'a dit à leurs
seins qui possède la manette en russie
le président poutine son ministre de la
défense et son chef d'état-major général
si aucun des trois n'a un moment un
résident l'année on ne peut pas le faire
croire le raisonne comme ans a fait
bloquer faisons aucune sauf sauf que
poutine comme commandant en chef peut
destituer une personne qui lui résiste
sa valeur est plein nommer une personne
à sa place qui va appuyer
donc c'est complètement irrationnel donc
sérieux et rationnel il ya que poutine
qui peut décider il ya pratiquement que
poutine qui peut décider ouais donc s'il
lui arrive à demain il se dit moi je
m'en fous j'ai envie que ce soit la fin
du monde mais il m'a bcc ce qu on avait
la même peur avec 30 mai mais raconter
quand 30 et arrivée au pouvoir on avait
absolument la même peur non mais s'il se
dit moi je suis malade gym reste plus
voilà j'ai plus rien à perdre je me
trouve je vais faire après mois les plus
d'humanité de le faire oui mathieu mais
moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est que général
qui est côté ouest et qui est très
rationnel n'est pas très inquiet mais
que sergey pendant la pub et je dirais
pas tout ce qui me dit mais des choses
intéressantes on a pu vous confier que
lui qui connaît bien la russie est
extrêmement inquiet justement de cette
troisième guerre mondiale donc ça
m'ennuie un petit peu leur est ce que
est ce que vous avez vu lorsque le
président poutine a annoncé qu'il même
placé les forces nucléaires stratégiques
en alerte la tête les deux généraux et
de colonels et aux autres mais deux ans
dire que eux ils se posent des questions
ouais ouais je suis d'accord bien sûr je
suis d'accord avec vous il est
destitué est nommé doit être destitué
elle me rassure mes maquettes général
bouzid
je
c'est une bonne vous avez raison on
parlait du de calme parce que dans ce
cas de figure où vraiment garder son
sang froid
vraiment garder son sang-froid et être
capable de contrôler la situation juste
une anecdote aujourd'hui le président
macron a appelé et a parlé pendant une
heure et demie à monsieur poutine
pourquoi pour qu'ils ne restent pas
isolé dans son coin absolument pour qui
est toujours un dialogue établi qui ne
soit pas enfermé dans sa bulle à devenir
de plus en plus paranoïaque ni et ça ça
fait partie de la dissuasion oui mais
oui mais général général donc ce que
vous dites c'est un peu comme comme
quand on est face à un forcené et
conflits on va garder convenable qu'il
faut aussi du plongeur
ou différents moments il va à dire je
vais aller du bon côté ou bien
chevaliers du mauvais côté dans bon ben
c'est ça est-ce même ce que vous dites
là vous nous rassurer encore une fois
fait les inquiéter parce qu'on se dit
mais combien de fois lorsque vous parlez
un forcené ça marche
c'est réussi ainsi c'est non mais
attendez comme vous le disiez je pense
pas qu'ils soient fous je pense qu'il a
des
effectivement des lubies les vision
paranoïaque que le coc vick qui a touché
beaucoup de monde elle a touché lui
parce qu'il est resté isolé pendant deux
ans dans son coin et c'est pour ça qu'il
faut lui parler c'est pour ça qu'il faut
avoir le dialogue avec lui et
l'avantagent avec mâcon c'est qu'il
décroche quand convaincante de maiden
lui téléphone ou quand les chinois lui
lui téléphone et décroche tandis que
pour certains les dix mois ils lui
disent quoi d'ailleurs justement parce
qu'on l'a dit la fois le président
chinois lui dit quoi vladimir poutine ce
qu'on sait que il va là la chine et la
russie ils ont de très bonnes relations
il lui dit quoi parce que c'est quand
même aussi une des clés de la fin du
conflit ce qui se passe entre le
président chinois et le président russe
non mais c'est vous avez raison c'est
une clé très importante mais les chinois
initialement n'ont pas critiqué l'action
russe en ukraine
seulement le chinois pour survivre dans
l'économie mondiale ils ont besoin du
monde parce que l'économie chinoise ne
fonctionne qu'avec le monde et donc
d'une certaine façon ils sont en train
de se dire aujourd'hui c'est le camarade
poutine y va un peu loin quand même lui
va et isolés nous on n'a pas envie
d'être isolé donc il temporisait
d'ailleurs dans les dés hier décision à
l'onu ils se sont abstenus ils n'ont pas
dit non se sont abstenus donc là aussi
il faut raison garder oui est ce qu'on
peut imaginer ce que vous avez évoqué
deux généraux qui étaient présents
avaient coûté mais ce qu'on peut
imaginer que l'armée se retourne contre
poutine alors moi si vous voulez c'est
un peu l'espoir que j'ai aujourd'hui non
seulement pas des jets de l'armée je ne
sais pas mais le peuple russe sergueï il
me dira peut-être mais ne voulait pas
cette guerre non et les images qui
viennent petit à petit très bien
instrumentalisés par les ukrainiens
qu'ils font très très bien à des chars
détruits des morts des blessés et serra
vont commencer à marquer la population
russe ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point c'est que le premier
cercle autour de poutine s'ils seront
que here is y avoir un problème et une
perte de pouvoir ils préféreront
éliminer le président pour garder le
pouvoir absolu mais ça c'est quelque
chose qui peut jouer en faveur d'une
certaine rationalité dans cette crise
parce que finalement quel est l'intérêt
du peuple russe à cette guerre une fois
aucun aucun aucun nom mais très grand
y'a pas le territoire on en a trop
il ya un autre et un autre point
important on en parlait tout à l'heure
sous les oligarques russes c'est ça
peuvent aussi aux impressions très
attendu steen je pense que ça c'est
vraiment très très importants apportant
ce que ça va guérir de la mairie ils ont
peut partir de la générale oui mais
c'est ce que je dit quand je parle du
premier set ils en font partie les gars
ça sinon on passe un moment il perd
énormément d'argent sachez le tous les
jours y perdre c'est des millions ou des
milliards dow et donc forcément à un
moment et vous dire bon ça et c'est ça
et puis la melville il va falloir qu'on
va falloir siffler la fin de la vraiment
là dedans une guerre de communication je
parlais de la communication des
ukrainiens qui la font très bien
la communication russe aujourd'hui va
perdre un peu pied par exemple dans la
aujourd'hui n'aurait communication du
président poutine vis à vis de la
population il faut qu'ils montrent
qu'ils négocient d'où la négociation qui
a lieu aujourd'hui qui a abouti à rien
du tout mais c'est pas grave ça lui
permet de dire voyez moi je veut
négocier sont les autres qui sont des
méchants mais au bout d'un moment tout
ça ça ça touche ses limites quand même